go ahead my name is food huh welcome
Baxter LEM jump we're gonna jump these
signs otherwise we get electrified hell
yeah all right so I'm replaying this
part with the hotel it's really short
it's only because the game crashed when
I recorded it so that's [ __ ] something
up there we go you're not so cocky
anymore are you hotel sign all right I
keep thinking like what the soundtrack
for Indiana Jones is and I looked it up
but now I forgot it again
[ __ ] don't enter now that's [ __ ]
Pirates of Caribbean it bothers me so
much I'm a little angry right now in
case you haven't noticed but I'm not in
the the past which you will you will
meet him in a couple minutes don't worry
he's a lot better nice the guy than me
I'm an [ __ ] all right jump your
little all right don't you dare die
that's right all right that's just let's
just [ __ ] finish this [ __ ]
what is that stupid [ __ ] sound I call
dad duh-duh-duh-duh let's stop yeah Oh
doctor doctor doctor
uh dr. da-da-da-da-da
da ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
ba ba ba
I press good now we can jump back to
Peter pie in the past is its kid can
dancing outro alright I do
nice dancing you're not gonna miss me
oh we going red my name is purify and
this is Jerry sup Jerry I feel good new
doo doo doo doo doo doo
welcome back to a [ __ ] Meg Jason Kreis
is dangerous I thought I was gonna kill
me for sure so far zero deaths let's see
how long we can make this life this time
around what is this
it's an era and it's pointing up it
probably fell down from the hotel sign
that's upstairs can we do anything with
this can we grab it
nope Jerry can only jump and click on it
that's lovely
what about these black we can't do
anything with these come on you little
[ __ ]
what do we do down here ah crabs amen
well [ __ ] me crabs amen
thank you great now I'm a zombie what is
that good it's not good for anything
well you gotta be a crab zombie once in
your life what you never been a crab
Sammy ha ha ha
that's funny you're funny alright that
repenteth crime semen that's ridiculous
ok so now we can finally pass the crab
semen shooter I guess the penis you
could call it black and hairy it's kind
of disgusting ok
let's keep going I got a hat my hat is
amazing give it a lick
it tastes like C but that's a very very
high
oh no the spikes gonna [ __ ] me over
aren't they no jarring
oh we're alive it's America all right
keep solving puzzles Jerry don't worry
about I told me no matter what you're
doing Jerry tell me what to do Jerry I'm
happy for your hat but seriously jump ah
a big jump Wow how long has this hadn't
gonna go what okay there's a button here
what does this do
but don't kill me oh no dad
[ __ ]
hell no each ray crab see me thank you
I'll thank God all right
oh no no no
all right we need to wait for it I
wonder if something is done here it
looks dangerous I'm not gonna jump in
this time around come back here you
little [ __ ]
now Gary what are you doing Jerry's
suicidal at small prayer Paul if you are
just going to fear for offensive nah hey
Gary you can't do it oh no all right all
right Brett all right all right
aah aah come on Gary I love you I don't
love anyone except Gary go now right in
the leg now
well done general entender I'm down the
road that I don't own - tre what Gary
Gary didn't turn to the dun dun dun dun
Tenterden don't turn to jump your boom
boom boom Wow
another epic jump from Jerry do I think
we need to balance this if we're gonna
get up they go down please
more more MORE
this is up bad plane thing ah
alright here we go
jump edge epic net Jerry get the [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
Kimmy we can move this I guess we're
supposed to swing us our ah no no no not
today J alright are you ready for this
Jerry dun dun dun dun dun dun dun dun it
done get er done
my sound truck does nothing alright here
we go
jump edge only died like three times so
far hope it doesn't slide on this I'm
happy for you bruh
you're doing great Jerry I'm proud of
you man alright let's solve these
puzzles that we came across so what does
these do alright jumping on it helps
that's cool and I can take it with me
why can I do this uh down how do I down
yeah whatever what it's gonna be a cheap
def here I know it Bruce
Gary stop blowing dicks jaysis cries but
I love it
stop it you disgust that we can't reach
it
why not Saul is a problem isn't it
what is this good for come up here how
do i how do I do it
maybe we can break the chain and drag it
over here I don't [ __ ] know
well exciting more Jerry now hahaha
your ass is mine now [ __ ] oh oh
gen tenten tenten tenten didn't so what
is this do exactly
besides I'm able to jump up here break
Calot oh hello there's a there's a rope
there alright let's try to make it go up
all right here's the deal Jerry we do
this
I'll give you dicks to blow just don't
die alright alright 30 don't enter Dada
Dada Dada Dada Dada you disappoint me
Jerry come on babe good at it you know
that I Jerry I'm scared why don't you
just do it you [ __ ] [ __ ] take a
jug oh baby what do we do now
ah my plan did not go further than this
then dented it and Underland didn't it
in it oh no I bought it
if I don't make it I want Larry to know
that I love him what is this good for
why are you what it's few thing out
seaman was that I yeah don't kill
yourself
it does spewed out semen what do we do
that semen I think is a better question
jump badge and the grab edge and then
this image semen there it is that it is
and then don't kill yourself Larry
there's a beautiful life out there
all right let's see what you do what are
you are you one I was just that [ __ ]
easter egg I'm not interested
1 out of 11 [ __ ] me why did I do all
that for that well I guess I'm too smart
this game just too easy on me pewds
always overthinking the [ __ ] puzzles
alright there we go that was not so
[ __ ] difficult was it alright come
here you little [ __ ] I kept trying to
parody that he should have pushed a box
well guess what I'm when I'm playing
this it's a couple what what is this
does not do anything why am I doing this
lalala lalala lalalala lalalala lalalala
hey dangles then it's pretty my penis is
some witty I like to be make it nifty so
I put on makeup here too
why this is not work ah good job Larry
nice going alright so maybe has delay on
it then I have to like take it yes
okay there we go
and now we dangle to Narnia I think I
can't let go
I can't wait too long otherwise I'd die
from the fall
all right kill me boxes no not this
again Oh No
I hate this soft thing ha oona boxes do
I boxes ha ha ha
we need to push it further aah
disgusting
all right plan plan out on kill me oh I
get it now
I have to kill myself lentil Owen I love
y'all please don't touch my nipples Oh
oh no its penis ass casting all right
Duncan deader than dantella and done get
a letter get it end and edit it I think
I pushed you soon come on baby come on
baby
Oh Jerri either a log we are such a
[ __ ] good team unite Jerry J that was
[ __ ] MLG yeah what is that some more
semen Easter egg over here why is it so
dark
hello what is that noise
why did what aah
more crab semen ha ha all right I found
a secret place but this thing is
blocking me now so why am i finding some
all right thumbnail beautiful this game
is really gorgeous it's funny funny I
like how it's the sign all right let's
keep jumping our way back and let's cut
all right let's go up here don't make
the ladder break my heart
I hate when ladders break my heart what
is that thing we're probably gonna touch
in what happens in the hotel plays I'm
so confused what that thing doesn't look
very friendly I guess we got a trick it
maybe I can fly it come here
does it see me I'm totally not visible
all right we're back with pills from the
pictures anyway what's that an episode
enjoyable all right well it go ahead and
leave a like a favorite if you enjoy
and I'll see you next time Joker
whenever I make love you rest
oh thank god thank God
set the octopus I'm stealing the octopus
it's my octopus now oh I'm sorry
get it Kenny gets your octopus that's
your octopus